hay dos formas de destituir a un
presidente de eeuu en funciones un
juicio político en el congreso o la
invocación de la enmienda 25 los
legisladores propusieron agregar esta
cláusula a la constitución en 1963 tras
el asesinato de john f.kennedy
claramente estaba destinado a aplicarse
cuando un presidente está incapacitado
física o mentalmente pero la sección 4
en la enmienda 25 permite una aplicación
más amplia a saber si un comandante en
jefe resulta ser peligrosamente
inadecuado para el cargo y se niega a
dimitir desde el momento en que se
invoca a la enmienda 25 el presidente
sería despojado de sus poderes y el
vicepresidente se convertiría en el
mandatario de más alto rango en el país
para que eso suceda mike pence y la
mayoría del gabinete de trump tendrían
que escribir al congreso declarando que
el presidente no es apto para el cargo
está la cv-60 garda fuera enviada al
congreso donald trump podría enviar una
carta de reputación pero luego si el
gabinete enviara una segunda carta de
ellos mismos al congreso eso sacaría
trump de la acción
axxion luego el congreso tiene hasta 21
días para resolver el problema o
realizar una votación se necesitaría una
mayoría de dos tercios de ambas cámaras
eso es 67 senadores y 290 miembros de la
cámara